[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another new
episode of myth America I make you Jeff
obviously we're not at the point where
there's a guest host yet but one day um
so I'm in New York got here a couple
days ago
um it's hot it's nice out though man I
was here in April and it was you know
flaming kind of cold which is beautiful
right now it's like the invigorating
it's just revitalizing right just
everything in it feels good you can see
out of all the endorsing and it's to be
just full of like people and activities
and you know a bunch of good shows to do
I'm really looking forward to having
like a great you know you can have here
so I'm recording this from New York so
if you're out here I'll be doing shows
mostly have to stand on 3rd Avenue in
like 19 and Fiat New York Comedy Club 2
and stand of New York and a couple other
shows Nick news.com for more details
there in San Francisco I'm headlining
the punchline July 6 through 8 so gern
SF come to one of those shows man
there'll be fun ones and then Tempe
improv July 22nd to 24th
let's keep this short actually have to
go do a spot at the stand in a little
bit so this episode is with my good
friend Steve Byrne he is just such a
good guy such a funny comic I was really
happy to sit down with him he's a busy
guy too so you know thank you
Steve again for taking the time to hang
out I went to his place we sat down and
just talked about now where it's from
he's he's half Korean half Irish East
Coaster grew up in Jersey moved to
Pittsburgh we talked about how his
parents met during the Korean War his
mom worked at one of the bases and he
just spent like a year to courting her
and and then they fell in love and he
and had even America and you know and it
goes from there so that's a he tell that
story and then talked about childhood
you know the hardships the good times
the bad times all it's tough finding
finding sports was a really good way for
him to channel a lot of his frustrations
and make friends and you know him
realizing he was like the funny guy he's
got a good handle on things man Steve
his um he's just he's got a good outlook
on stuff and if you've ever seen him
live you know you know he's such a great
comic it's such a good dude you know
he's always one of those guys that I say
that about like I always make sure to a
lot of comics are funny and stuff and
but you always want to be like and he's
a really good guy because not a lot of
those you find some funny dudes but then
when they also are like really cool down
earth like loyal honest like rad people
he'd be one of those guys so glad glad
to call him a friend I'm glad to be able
to work with him on the road glad he was
able to do this podcast ah we get into a
bunch of stuff so I'm just going to stop
here and let you guys explore the
episode and let me know what you think
Nick America pottage email or contact at
Nick Youssef comm if you've already been
using that one
that's still there you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at Nick Youssef
and follow Steve Byrne on social media
as well Steve Byrne live and watch his
new special his new Showtime special
just came out please
six three weeks ago by now and it's a
good one like all those others which one
or two of those are available on Netflix
Google around find his comedy support
his comedy let them know what you think
of this episode and you know what that's
it man let's go walk the streets of New
York go do a spot at the stand maybe get
a slice of pizza and then get up early
do it all over again see you later
okay thanks for having me in your home
you're welcome Nicholas a wonderful
guest I'm a wonderful feel comfortable
bringing you in heaven you're twice in
two days yeah yeah twice in twelve hours
maybe yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah
um it was uh I could have been a bad
guest and you would have been like let's
not record this it in my house estimated
1/3 like a park surprise you hear this
time because there's no food that's true
actually that's true we'll just order in
you gain will appear yeah comfortable
yeah yeah I'm gonna live here actually
in this drop in this area I grew up 20
minutes
well 15 minutes west of here yeah in
Long percenter or Pasadena
or family room you live quite close to
the show yeah well when I when I came by
yesterday I was visiting my parents oh
you were yeah so they're gonna work out
great anyway because I was hanging out
there a little longer then drive
straight over here yeah you tell your
parents you have a new place but you're
living now yeah yeah I'm gonna go I
can't visit you for as long as I have
another house and they have better a
Korean barbecue you have [ __ ]
Lebanese food unless you learn this
recipe yeah but yeah that's where I
spent my childhood they live in the same
house that I grew up in that's crazy
then we're no awesome for you so you
never had that like like home doesn't
feel like a time capsule to you then or
does it um now for a little while it did
because my my bedroom was stayed the
same so when I moved out and came I
would go oh yeah this you know this this
bed is still here this yeah you know box
full of whatever but that stuff slowly
starts getting put into like storage and
then like they now turn that bedroom
into like you know like sort of a guest
room it like a relative is going to
visit or something if it's a small
bedroom it's like a big deal but yeah
it's just a guest bedroom with the cure
posters all right yeah the water yeah my
bedroom door has still has stickers that
they never removed what it'll be like
k-rock the local rock station yeah and
then like there's a blink-182 sticker a
Smith's parking or Smith's ticket stub
right yeah yeah Taylor la forme yeah
yeah yeah so that's that the door the
time caps
okay I think I'll say that and I go oh
[ __ ] I like that band you should take
that door down what do you mean do what
was it like like replace it but if
there's that many stickers on it you
should take the door and like that's
your childhood door that'd be kind of
cool yeah and like put it yeah yeah that
could be cool this has that it's like
maybe 10 12 stickers but yeah I don't
know you can what you know you put that
up in your your home or whatever because
I think like I'm jealous of you because
my pitch my home in Pittsburgh is sold
and yeah I would love to have gotten to
go back and see my old ya head room I I
think a lot of people would but you you
get to do that yeah and then yeah so you
sort of like I mean it's kind of a good
feeling because you're like oh yeah my
childhood home into so many kids like
you know moved around or their parents
retired somewhere else yeah yeah but
then I think like their you don't get to
miss as much you know so like my friends
who'll go fly home and visit once every
year too and see how things have changed
and right yeah sort of thing I that's
always been 20 minutes away from me so
yeah good and it's not as much nostalgia
because you have you see it evolve every
year so you don't go like what happened
is this place yeah like I saw that place
closed down there's a for Lisa doesn't
build a new place you know yeah so like
when the first Starbucks opened and you
know they redid the the local
supermarket at the Trader Joe's moved or
something you kind of watch it happen
yet like when I first moved here you
told me to go to pine pine burger right
yeah yeah mint is a burger burger I am
burger yeah which would be the opposite
way to eat it that'd be a horrible way
to have your meal I first end there but
oh but yeah you told me about that and
so it must be nice to have those like
that place hasn't changed since probably
the 50s yeah that's sure didn't the same
forever yeah the prices barely have gone
up I don't think either previously
though is it now yeah it was like nine
bucks for a burger someone like of
anything I guess they have yeah it was
worth it yeah really good yeah it's good
cash only
yeah definitely a time capsule yeah yeah
this like that's I mean I like that
aspect of it like when people move to
these parts you know right now you're
like you know your your marriage of kids
your
to move out of like Holly wrote them oh
yes not publicly I don't want anybody
know I'm married at all yeah 28 28
single no family I'm an orphan actually
I don't talk about any family
yeah I actually live with the lesbian
and two cats so when you moved in with
your lesbian the two cap yeah you needed
more space I I need more space yeah that
I love when people discover like
Pasadena and like you know La Crescenta
locking you out of Montrose and stuff
and they go have you ever heard like
yeah I [ __ ] spent my childhood in the
new van halen's from yes yeah anybody
who grew up here yeah there's a really
good diner on I'm like I've been going
there for 23 years yeah and then they go
so I like telling people about that
stuff that I go dude if you're gonna
live here there's this Park you got to
eat there you got to go there yeah and
they kind of so that makes me feel sort
of more at home in a weird way yeah
because then it's like I can talk about
places that before people have had
people a lot of people don't even know
where the 210 and the two are why they
always it I'm like yeah Angeles National
Forest of you know what's that I'm like
that's why people complain there's no
like oh there's no like you know nature
in LA I'm like if you look at a map yeah
it's everywhere yeah drive up the
Angeles National Forest and 20 15 20
minutes like you're seeing more stars
there's no city lights yeah that's where
you go watch like you know meteor
showers and that kind of show yeah I
mean here we're right next to Eaton
Canyon Park yeah and there's a waterfall
yeah and yeah it's called the weekends
people the parking lot get so full
people park into our neighborhood yeah
and when those torrential downpours
happen in February uh-huh that place was
awesome because if we're full-on like
you felt like you're in Colorado yeah
like oh this is what it's like we're
yeah so the first walk there are some
excellent nature but yeah there's tons
to do here the John Muir Trail yeah is
in Northern California
Yosemite I'm shocked at how many people
don't go to Yosemite and it's like it
you better San Fran you might as well
just go yeah it's not that far it's
gorgeous it's it's right here in our
backyard
yeah yeah when people say like there's
nothing to do over the weekend you're
like that's a day trip you could do that
without staying
like at like a hotel or anything like
that but um but yeah I like those parts
of LA that people kind of kind of forget
me weird though too like Chris you grew
up here and now you live in Hollywood it
must be like going through a Stargate
because I mean this is like so far
removed from Hollywood you're close to
it yeah I mean listen here it's like
we're in my backyard yeah I can't hear
anything at night it's super quiet and
it's very suburban and you come here you
don't feel like you're in Hollywood if
you'll remove but Hollywood's right
there
it is yes loud and dirty and skanky and
trashing and rich and everything yeah
everything's right there so must be so
weird to like have grown up in La
Crescenta yeah which is I mean La
Crescenta la cañada are kind of like you
know pretty well-to-do kind of talent
yacht is yeah that's pretty represent is
not as well understand is like a
middle-class like the town city I'm
going to call it and then Tujunga a
little further west is like a more kind
of lower-class it's a little better
nowadays but yeah you know locking yata
was so locking yata basically you have
like one Latino in your class La
Crescenta if you're like five Latinos oh
yeah yeah I decided oh you have you're
the minority you know it was mostly the
layout was like this la cañada was like
the cars were way nicer the houses were
way bigger yeah you'd go to people's
house and you're like how is there a
five bedroom house like yeah what do you
who even uses all all these bedrooms
like yeah there's two stories you know
there's like some big nice houses and
it's like mostly white it's a ton city
like La Crescenta and to hunger all in a
part of LA County like oh yeah is its
own City it has its own School District
like it's very wealthy yeah so we would
have nothing in common with the kids
over there so we would hang out with the
kids from Tujunga because I mean none of
us knew what the inside of a Lexus
looked like and like that you know
what's your story house they are leather
seats what is it yeah exactly so but
what was weird about over there and they
were like um like some like skinheads
and like white supremacist named
Kenyatta and no and Tujunga Oh
so part of my childhood was like kind of
like being sort of around them it was a
really bizarre thing there's a lot of
white flight that happened in like the
70s and 80s from right LA and Glendale
and that sort of thing and so when like
I guess a lot of Armenians and like you
know there's a big Korean population
around like La Crescenta and that area
it's a lot of like white people were you
starting to move away yeah so to my
surprise I was like there are like
neo-nazi types that live here because
you go eight or ten minutes east you're
in LA cañada where it's very wealthy and
like slightly conservative and like but
in less safe way you know and then you
go to Tujunga and you're like oh wow you
know that the cars you know everyone's
driving like you know 60s 70s era like
you know beat-up kind of muscle cars and
yeah you'd never see higher-end vehicles
but a few minutes this direction a few
minutes that direction everything and we
were kind of right in the middle yeah so
blocking out a mostly white La Crescenta
mostly white but a lot of Korean
Armenian some Latino and then like I
think I had my high school two or three
black kids yeah but you want ages in
your class you don't get you want to get
good grade so you wanna get around eat
or you want to raise the bar high middle
school and high school there were two
full pages devoted to the last name Kim
sort of guys there is like one and then
the other side and you flip again there
were that many kids and then Lee was
another that's crazy that's pretty fun
and none of them were related yeah of
course [ __ ] nuts how many is crazy
that's funny I mean you you you know you
get married to another Kim you don't
have to change your towels yeah
everything's nice yeah yeah yeah the
only research you have to do is like way
are we related like we should really
figure yeah before our kids come out
weird let's go to ancestry.com and make
sure we're not Lea so okay where did
where give me the lad of where you grew
up
well I was born in in freehold New
Jersey and I lived there till about
fourth or fifth grade and in Jersey it
was basically where's my visa like well
from old it well Springsteen's for
freehold okay so he made like highway
nine inboard to run I
right off highway 9 whoa cool arm right
off that and it was all I was just
talking to somebody who grew up uh in
Toms River which is right by a Jersey
okay and when you're growing up in
Jersey
you're either Italian or Jewish and his
bagels in a pizza in every strip mall so
you know anybody grew up in Jersey it
just you grew up with that memory of
having fresh bagels fresh pizza and it
didn't taste like anywhere else but it
was you know it was basically I think
like because you're so close to New York
City you still have that diversity so I
never grew up thinking anything
different of like somebody else I never
grew up thinking you know uncomfortable
around being invited to bat mitzvahs or
bar mitzvahs when I was just like he's
just kids I'm in class with that you
don't know any better and your black
kids and Hispanic kids so everybody was
was kind of in my Township when I was
growing up so it was I think there were
two or three other Asian kids in my
class so it was it was really diverse
and then I moved to Pittsburgh and then
you're just I mean it's just a lot of
Polish people a lot of white people
Irish and being Korean Irish I was I was
definitely one of I think I think maybe
for Asians in the whole you know middle
school well really not as diverse but
they you know at that point where you're
like mom dad what the [ __ ] let's move
back to where I was kind of when you
realize you're different I mean when you
you know you get it a little bit from
your friends in grade school but when I
moved like fifth or sixth grade to
Pittsburgh its junior high school kids
are learning they can be mean and um
like oh this works that's the first time
I remember feeling like I remember going
home I distinctly have a memory because
my father I thought it well we played
baseball in Jersey and this is some kid
called me [ __ ] and then this other the
team started calling me [ __ ] I was
playing baseball and I was like dad what
is it [ __ ] and I thought it was kind of
a comment I was I got at school I'm a
good baseball play I'd no clue you know
my dad's like well it's a derogatory
term
we use in a negative way then you're
like that derogatory yeah yeah so use it
because you know I think when you're
when you're something else you never
know anything else until the first time
somebody points a finger goes you're
different yeah yeah and that's when I
experienced oh I'm different and then I
remember looking at the mirror and like
putting my hands over my eyelids and
just rubbing them and like I'm different
I guess my eyes are different than
everybody else's I was just doing this
and like staring at my eyes like my eyes
don't look different to me yeah I guess
other people see it differently and then
I was looking at my mom and I was just
staring at her dinner like I guess she
has different eyes I didn't never knew
that you know and that was the first
time I realized I'm Korean okay I am
different I'm and then of course you are
embarrassed by it you don't affect it
and then uh I remember my father when I
moved to Pittsburgh he was always
reffering hockey games on the side
because he just loved to skate just make
it extra money
um just refereeing hockey games and he
plays as well so he's like this is a
great way for you to make extra money I
want you to be a linesman I'll be the
referee you make like 50 bucks a game in
the weekend you make a few hundred bucks
you'll be off to the ways it's good
money my kids great yeah she's an
awesome sign me up I took a class I took
the test I got my whistle I got the
outfit I go out and the first game I
blew a call I blew an offsides call and
this team just laced into me and these
are all kids probably my age at the time
problem you know 12 13 or whatever and
everything in the book everything racial
in the booklet could imagine you could
call an Asian I've heard it all of him
five minutes every time I skated past
them I heard it I you know you're going
up and down the aisles like families
around with the families around coach
didn't call it I'm in tears emulating
tears crying with the referee outfit on
oh my dad just comes over to me at a
break he goes Steve it's okay just you
can go off the ice I said thank you and
I skated off the ice and my dad
walked over your skated over to the team
and he said you know that's actually my
son and he won't I'll be reffering the
rest of the game because um we didn't
appreciate what your team did afterwards
the coach came over and apologized to my
father but I never wrapped another
hockey game again and it was one of
those things where you come home you're
in tears my mom's like what's wrong you
know I just devoted two weeks to like
learning this stuff yeah and I got money
coming in and I remember my mom crying
you know my mom was in tears and she was
so embarrassed and she was like I should
have never moved to this country she
took it on herself way too hard you know
and I should have never you know moved
over here I'm so sorry did this to you
guys and just like no and and in that
regard it kind of strengthens the bond
between my brother and I with my mom and
it made us stronger and I think
obviously as you get older you start to
learn to accept who you are and
appreciate your differences I think like
yes like you know being an x-man I think
you know when you're young in those in
those movies these kids are all
embarrassed by their powers yeah and
then you go to this gifted school you
like it's kind of a unique trait that I
probably will melt steel beams with my
eyeballs so I don't know that's that's
what I learned I was I was different you
know yeah Wow so how did you try and
like you said something about like
denying it or hiding it or being ashamed
of it like what did you was there
anything specific that you did yeah look
what I like white it up a lot you know
well you definitely don't want to you
know I was adverse to taking Taekwondo
my dad any time my mom or her relatives
came over and my cousin's they all speak
in Korean I was like I'm never learning
that I don't want to learn that and it
wasn't until I got to college I'm like I
was so ashamed I'm like I want to learn
to speak Korean so yeah I spent two
years studying Korean in college and of
course with any language you got to keep
up on it I drifted off but it was fun to
like would you speak with your mom at
least when you were yeah yeah yeah that
was that was great to call my mom and
she would help me with my homework now
when I was growing up my mother was so
embarrassed by the fact that she would
go out and still to this day speak
broken English that she would take
English classes so ever since I was a
little kid up until I was in college my
mother once or twice a week would go to
some Community College Center English
classes and so I remember growing up in
4th 5th 10th you know freshman in
college helping my mom with her homework
I never had a mom that helped me with my
homework so yeah I was always helping
her so it was kind of nice in college to
finally have my mom help me with my home
really it was kind of cool do you still
speak Korean now no I've definitely
trailed off I know you know how to say
hello how to say thank you I was just in
Korea on a USO tour for the first time
and I actually got to go visit the camp
that my mother was stationed at Camp
Humphreys invasion de in Seoul Korea not
she was a station she was working there
my father was stationed at Camp hump
yeah no she was working as a waitress
and my father met her there they fell in
love and he brought her back two years
later so that's been uh it was a cool to
go not only to Korea you know and
entertain the troops but it was great to
be on the base that my mom worked at and
what much has been renovated now that
it's one of the largest bases in Seoul
so they're doing this transfer of power
now so all those bases along the DMZ are
getting consolidated and turned over to
their South Korean government and so a
lot of the troops are moving just to
further bit south to Camp Humphreys so
it I think it's like I forget I think
it's 17 acres I know if that sounds
right but it's magic own city
it's a massive them a hospital they have
like you know every town they have like
the Chili's the Applebee's the movie
theater or the roller skating they have
that there and you don't know if you
like it basically you don't feel like
you're in Korea you feel like you're in
Iowa it's crazy there's like a Starbucks
and yeah fast food places and like all
of it yeah Burger King Popeyes Encarna
baskin-robbins but to be on that base
like I did get a slightly emotional
great ofthose a Koreatown Korean well
they have an American town they have an
American town married about American
village in Korea outside of camp Osan
and we had one of my jokes in in my
second hour special like I was like you
know every city has a Chinatown would it
be great to have an American town I
remember that yeah just a bunch of fat
people looking for Wi-Fi divin food and
ranch dressing right and then I actually
saw America Village and it was just this
one Street with a bunch of like chain
restaurants and very totally fun yeah
it's kind of cool that's crazy
so wait so your parents met she worked
on the base she worked on the base as a
waitress yet and her name was candy not
oak true cuz all the like that's not
your name anymore here yeah all the
locals who is some the guy who hired him
all gave them all like American names
look on their name tag
yeah that's funny yeah so then they met
and like like kind of fell in love
quickly or was it one of those like yet
he would see her over a period of time
and then yeah I think a lot of those
girls obviously have their guard up
because it's just like oh you're just
another dude yeah it laid yeah and you
know they they definitely definitely
courted her for a while they dated and
then you know two years you got a you
going back home it's like for the two
years he was there uh yeah yeah
Wow yeah I'd say like a year and a half
okay cuz he courted her for a bit yeah
yeah you know she was resistant and yak
my kind of [ __ ] right yeah so yeah and
then they they they move back here they
lived in Minnesota for another two years
and then they move in over here
Seattle's permanently my father actually
there was stationed in Minnesota but my
father actually grew up in New York City
and Stuyvesant Town which is a like
Lower East Side right and Stuyvesant
Town is known for being this beacon of
Education back in the day yeah it was
very innovative and it was one of the
most sought-after like kind of public
schools not only in the country but
definitely New York City yeah and you
know a lot of what's going on with our
education system
the downfall occurred slightly
thereafter but it was it was in its
heyday was it was known for its great
education my father to this day is one
of the smartest guys ever met my life
you know he's one of those guys that
just knows a little something about
everything yeah all those things in our
textbooks that we were forced to
memorize just for the test for some
reason with their education system back
then you were forced to learn it not to
memorize it yeah I'm going to understand
the self yeah concepts all everything so
everything that I memorized I've
forgotten I'm really upset at my
education system but my father had a
great education and he's just a great
dude half of that so why do they end up
in Minnesota stationed there after the
military they were at another base there
and then he you know he could have
signed up again but he decided I'm going
to get on with my life so he uh he moved
to Jersey and ended up owning a fish
market and a sporting goods store in the
same strip mall so he's running two
businesses at the same time and I
remember my childhood was was riding
around in a big wheel throughout the
strip mall so much like Danny and the
shining is going around the the motel
yeah that was me I was always going
through the thing with my big wheel I
knew all the shop owners I'd go into the
pizza store next door they'd give me a
cup of fresh fresh-cut mozzarella cheese
and I just sit outside and eat my cheese
I go in I was like that it was it was
the best and he would be making like
iron-on t-shirts at a sporting goods
store
I remember Chris kiss used to scare the
[ __ ] out of me because kiss was popular
at the time see all these kiss iron-ons
and Star Trek and Star Wars iron-ons as
a kid it was like [ __ ] awesome I
always had fresh pressed Star Wars
iron-on shirts
Wow and then he lost a new like some
landlord screwed him out of the deal so
my dad had to get get going and then he
went back to community college got a
degree and he started working at a
seafood company but then his big gig was
working for the yellow pages and so he
became a salesman for the L pages then
like a manager and this is what
everybody used the yellow pages yeah for
the internet so you always had to use
the yellow pages
and he got transferred to Pittsburgh and
that's how I ended up moving there but
yeah growing up we were not wealthy at
all yeah yeah I remember when my father
even lost his job with the yellow pages
you know it's just eating spaghetti
literally for two months we ate
spaghetti every day for two months we
just had nothing it was a it was kind of
nerve-wracking and I look back on that
time I can't imagine you know like
myself having a wife and two kids like
not being able to provide for my family
yeah [ __ ] are we gonna do it's kind of
scary times Wow um and then your mom was
she just working at the before that in
in the sporting goods store in the fish
marshy was helping out but she she she
worked the graveyard shift
si uh at a light bulb light bulb Factory
uh-huh so she would come home and you
know basically when we're back from
school she'd be taking a nap so she's
like get out you know babies hit her
just for open the door go they're out of
the house I got to sleep so my brother
and I would just go out and we lived
across the street from a farm on one
side the other side was another strip
mall there's this kid named not Joe and
his father's name is Tony and hit day on
the pizza shop yeah so what we would do
is we would go through hook we would we
would go through the whole strip mall
every day and finally minim cans put in
a garbage bag go over this place where
you could recycle the cans and it would
dispense change to you and we'd get like
a dollar in quarters and me we basically
spent two hours collecting aluminum cans
to spend four quarters within four
minutes on Donkey Kong it was the worst
the horse payoff ever Donkey Kong so
complicated but Joe's dad owned the
pizza shop so we just put the quarters
and they were making money but in turn
they'd always give us a slice pizza yeah
so it's kind of good it all kind of
worked out so we'd have a slice of pho
coke and we spent all afternoon getting
aluminum cans and every now and then my
brother would ride the mechanical horse
in front of the thing and we used to
like this is like Brett when
breakdancing was big we set up cardboard
in front of where people enter and exit
we put a hat up front no one will break
dance for people we were [ __ ] awful
I mean garbage I had money and like you
to the apparently Khalid yeah we now
then you get a quarter something or a
dime and then we go back or and tapper
was the other one
tapper was [ __ ] was the other video
game you know no work you guys did to
play Donkey Kong games yeah I can't lift
any anis Wow
so we did that and that was kind of like
the childhood back then and then
obviously in Pittsburgh it was much
different I I was so involved in hockey
I was playing on a travel team on my
middle school team and like when I was
in eighth grade I was playing varsity
hockey Wow so I was I was really really
obsessed with hockey I loved it I was
playing at the tennis courts all the
time in high school we live right by the
park so I was obsessed with Hokkien at
the time Mario Lemieux and the Penguins
and Jaromir Jagr was a dynasty and to
get to grow up with not only idolizing
hockey but literally one of the greatest
players of all time is playing during
your run of growing up there yeah it was
I just got so lucky it's it was the best
said adjoining like did like playing
sports and having like a sort of like a
community within the community make you
feel like more accepted yet look moving
to Pittsburgh at that time was the worst
thing you could put a kid through
because junior high schools you know
you're going through puberty infused you
feel isolated nobody gets you mnemonics
it in yeah it was [ __ ] awful you want
to be cool you're into you're
discovering girls for the first time
right and I moved right at that moment
and it was [ __ ] awful I'll never
forget my first day I was on the bus I
was the last pickup to go to the high
school because I lived so close so I
walked after this incident to high
school because I was like a [ __ ] on
my bus I go on the bus there's one empty
seat is next to a girl and I sat in the
aisle instead of the girl why I was so
nervous and like stage fright and
uncomfortable I didn't know anybody know
a soul and this kid said something he's
like why don't you sit next to that girl
will you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I go I'm not a [ __ ] I'm crusher bone
Smith what the [ __ ] I have no idea why
the [ __ ] I said that and this kid oh no
became one of my best friends named
Brian Doherty and he was a cool kid he
knew everybody she goes as soon as I get
in the school he goes be where everybody
that's crush your bones Smith call me
crusher bone Smith for like two weeks
and it was so [ __ ] you know my few
weeks back then it feels like in the
term my god got made fun of I'll get on
got ostracize eating lunch by yourself I
mean you can't even eat with the Nerds I
remember walking to the first dance by
myself not knowing a soul and everybody
had to sign like Talbots you know 92
clubs whatever the thing is that you
know little pep rally sonic and I wrote
crusher bone Smith and just like I feel
deceitful to myself just write your own
name you're a loser and it was just so
uncomfortable and I remember this one
kid his name's John satola
and I ended up becoming friends with him
and his family after this but for two
weeks maybe like a week he just called
every time I passed him in the hall he
called me [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and he just
stayed on his breath he didn't even
really know why he was just like I
thought guys just yeah I gotta just say
that it makes me feel look better
yeah myself somehow and you just are
like [ __ ] is wrong with this kid so I
told my dad but that's like you calls
you that again tomorrow
beat [ __ ] cool but like alright signed a
hoarders my dad in a fight before that
ever uh yeah like little tussles in
Stalag worry like oh yeah are like they
are you're like round of [ __ ] but
nothing major okay so this kid lo and
behold I walk down the hall next day
[ __ ] I it was like Ralphy from a
Christmas story
all that rage and anger that have been
building up for a week but it get this
kid on the ground
[ __ ] well yeah punch and punch and a
pull me off pull him on with another kid
was like that's why they call him
crusher so I got pulled off and then
after that I was just like you know I'm
not going to take this I'm not gonna you
know yeah and what I learned was in
retrospect
that's what I developed a sense of humor
because I was like I'm not cool I'm
after you beat the living [ __ ] out of a
kid doesn't like I'm funny and then
looking back I'm sure I didn't beep like
you know not like a gong Club and I'm
sure it was like two or three punches
yeah and then we got separated you know
it is my mind it's like cows bucket well
yeah and blood everywhere but um but
yeah you know I was just like what what
can I do to garner friends yeah and so
you know you try a few different things
and then all sudden one day you make a
kid laugh it's like I'm gonna make
people laugh
yeah and then I developed a sense of
humor and over the course of those six
years that I was in Pittsburgh those
formative years during high school in
high school I was just goofy and
insecure and always quick to make a joke
yeah my high school was so great because
there's some there's some teachers or
faculty that I'll see you exhibit
something and shun that whereas Hampton
Township for me they really provided me
with it the outlet to do things I
remember my history teacher mr. Garber I
think in eighth grade he and I did a
spot-on impression of him back then he
he talked like this and it were a
high-pitched when he was emotional and I
developed this impression and he'd go
all right you guys are good today Steve
can impersonate me the last two minutes
of class really and so cool a feature
ever yeah I would just impersonate him
for two minutes to make the class laugh
make him laugh and then when I got to
high school I at the end of the pep
rally they would let me go up and just
do whatever you want they go okay here's
a microphone a now Steve Byrne and Emily
I was I would prepare something for the
pep rally was usually basically you were
doing stand-up I was basically doing
stand-up for the pep rally and so the
faculty and staff there were like you
know he exhibits this showmanship let's
let him do that
and every pep rally I got to do
something fun and creative mo you know
the talent show I got to do something
fun and creative and you know you get
voted class clown and everything but
never in a million years think I'm gonna
make a living out of it I'm just like of
all I'm just the wacky friend down at
surviving now in school dress yeah yeah
yeah you're loud and I you know you get
voted class clown and you go on with
your life and never in a million years I
was never in a stand-up never wanted to
watch stand-up remember when I was
growing up everybody had the eddie
murphy and dice cassette tapes that they
would pack never listen to it never hi
Carol I was just goofing off yeah wow I
can't believe the teachers like you
either see that on TV shows or in movies
where they like okay at the end of the
class you like that [ __ ] never happens
yeah never lets students do that [ __ ]
but yeah I've heard now a few different
times yeah I remember mr. garvik that's
so cool remember I I took my shoes he'd
always draw the curtains and stuff like
it was this like AC unit or whatever it
is and I put my shoes on top of it so it
looked like I was standing behind the
curtains and I hid in the closet and I
remember I put my she was kind of
towards his desk and he went a half hour
without even noticing that I wasn't in
the classroom and then he saw these
shoes he goes you know he's like burn
get outta there and then he comes over
and pulls it back and I was in the
closet I was like when were you gonna
you know I was dying in that closet he's
like yeah and the class all laughed and
stuff but like I think some teachers
would be like you go on to the
principal's office
yeah [ __ ] out here we have time for this
but he didn't laughed it off and he
noticed the greatest thing and I don't
know I look back on that time it's just
like what if you'll dude respected that
teacher more - right yeah yeah a really
laid-back he's kind of easy to get along
with because yeah there's always a
pushback when the teachers really strict
then a lot of kids like want to do
something else to get under their skin
or they just like automatically dislike
Authority yeah the teachers like
laughing and you know having a good time
with the students like feel like they're
more likely to listen when they're
supposed to yeah I think it's the same
with a parent too I mean he had friends
that had super strict parents and those
are the first kids to do drugs you have
a [ __ ] buckwild and go crazy yeah and
I dated a girl in high school that her
parents were super strict and these kids
got straight A's they were good students
and the minute they graduate and were
off on their own just you know squat
loose or something on all of them
they're all kind of and you're thinking
these kids are gonna be successful yeah
they just went crazy great thing and the
leash came off they were like drugs and
yeah yeah well different different kind
of kids so did you eventually like
through high school become like you
found like your footing sort of you were
like okay now I got some friends people
like me you know because I'm like funny
and yeah and I get along with people and
then like you figured out there was no
how soon after that I can't sit next to
a girl on the bus turned into like I can
finally talk to some girls and well I
mean look I I was always insecure with
girls I never kissed a girl until I
graduated high school I graduated Earl
and she was a freshman and uh it wasn't
until like college I think that's why
College were those years even if you
don't go to college between 18 and 22
those are such formative years because I
think that's when you really discover
you're on your own for the first time
that's when you can truly discover who
you are and I was always insecure with
girls I and I felt being Asian was a
hindrance in terms of you know being
attractive to girls I mean what girl is
gonna date an Asian dude especially in
the 90s one hip hop so huge and yeah you
know on ESPN it's black athletes all the
time and you know it's just like what I
have to look forward to you know yeah
what inspiration why it's like Bruce Lee
died nearly four I was born so freely it
that's all you got to look forward to in
terms of even like pop-culture
references it'll know like like
masculine sort of like hero figure of
the community I guess nothing nothing so
you know so I got to college and that's
when you know it was like I remember the
first time this girl was attracted to me
I was like what this is crazy you're
attracted this is nuts and she was
really cute girl yeah um
the kind of girl that would like come in
the dorm and all the guys back she would
this dude
and on you know you're just kind of
shocked and and I'll never forget she
goes I think you have gorgeous eyes and
I was like it goes against everything I
was conditioned to believe when I start
thinking this woman's crazy there's a
completely delusional I'm like yeah you
must be high did you smoke eyes white or
about they come and take every
conversation yeah that makes sense yeah
in the local mental ward but she was she
was saying now you go great and I never
known that I had green eyes until that
girl had mentioned it I'd gone 18 19
years of my life without knowing I green
colored eyes how's that even you've
never filled out a form what color
everybody ever said anything to me
nobody complimented nobody acknowledged
it I just never cuz you grow up just
look at yourself every day in the mirror
you don't think anything different I
never did did you think like I'm I'm I
don't have attractive features growing
up or did you just not even think about
because that's how I was because I was
not like I was a very late bloomer and
oh yeah like the only thing I had was I
was tall by didn't carry that well like
I was like hunched over and kind of just
I was not comfortable my own skin so
like I never had any sort of like you
have good blank whatever the feature was
right it was always like you're you have
a big nose you're like you know like
awkward and unpopular so no one said
anything positive right so for me and
about you I took it and started thinking
in the negative like oh I'm ugly oh yeah
and my insecurities got to where I
thought every like a lot of features
were like bad and like I wish I had
essentially my thing was I wish I was
white because that's what is considered
attractive yeah I I agree with that and
I look I also had this is on my left out
I had a horrible horrible acne growing
up oh yeah mine is kind of that really
bad acne okay how bad my acne was my
acne was so bad my senior class picture
my parents didn't order any conference I
got for that reason it was so bad
they're like oh my we're gonna live in
the yearbook they oh yeah but it's black
and white but still you'd probably be
able to see
fiving Colorado Earth there used to be
days where my acne was so bad I didn't I
faked sick because I couldn't go to
class my underwear hat in high school I
couldn't it was no my forehead and
always on my cheeks always on my cheeks
it was so bad and so when you have like
bad acne and you're 110 pounds yeah and
were you tall and because you're pretty
tall I'm tall now but when I was a
freshman sophomore and I'd even say
junior year I was always one of the
shortest in my class okay my senior year
I don't know what happened but I just
shut up I think I was five six when I
was a freshman because I remember the
this the newspaper wrote an article
about me plant on your Oh what I was on
the ice yeah I was just drilling people
but okay cool
I remember in tiny and I was always one
of the smallest fastest kids and I was
like yeah it's gonna be fast and then
senior year I just sprouted up and uh
yeah acne bad I didn't know what hair
products were my dad didn't have hair so
I don't know what pomade was or a gel or
anything I just went in and I wet my
hair down the morning and then just pop
boost out during the day it was thick
Asian it was I money mess if I was
Angelina Jolie would never adopt me if
she saw me that one of those how bad
that's how bad it was that's funny
bad bad bad so yeah I definitely felt
unattractive
I had no self-confidence no self-worth
you got to use that line in your standup
yeah Angelina wouldn't even the dot mean
I think it's it's the old adage and so
many people tell you this when you're
younger it's like just remember all the
cool kids now are not going to be so
cool yeah it really does go the olives
away yeah the late bloomers end up
figuring out you know yeah they you know
they become like immuno more attractive
or come into their own and then they
like keep all the skills and and things
that they spent learning when they were
younger because they weren't popular you
know like you're eating and educating
themselves and knowing should about pop
culture and then it becomes this like
combination of like really cool things
is where the kids that were popular in
school just spent all that time sitting
around playing sports and then now
they're all like you know
falen yeah and they you know they got
married early but yeah I think it's good
to go through that because you it's just
like if you became famous at 22 he
became as famous at 42 right you're
gonna appreciate a lot more 42 then even
more grounded exactly oils down to like
if you're the later you become
successful in whatever it is like
popularity career whatever you've gone
through so much [ __ ] provided you know
become like a bitter [ __ ]
we were grounded about it yeah you know
because it's so funny to hear you say
you're a late bloomer which I wouldn't
assume but because I've always known you
as being like this cool you know I
wouldn't say brooding but like there's
like a dark fun presence about you yeah
and mysterious and like like if you were
in high school now you'd be like the
cool guy that's in alternative music
right great sense humor and so it's so
funny to like hear that about you
because when we work together on the
road
I'll come out of the green room a little
later and you'll be at the bar you know
and there'll be like five or six girls
around you right and you're holding
court and think about you is you won't
even go out with them you'll just be
like talking oh my flirting you're not a
pig you're good dude but it's like so
nice to think of like what you used to
be in high school and yeah well you you
think I'm never going to get laid and
I'm never going to be here and then
flash-forward and I mean I did have a
period of time where I just would
because it was a consent of like oh I
can I can get girls and I can get lay so
I would I was like making up for lost
time and yeah getting revenge on my old
self or it's like okay now you can't now
do this go figure this out or yeah you
know and then like you kind of I'm 35
now it's like you got to calm down at
some point you know yeah yeah yeah but
yeah it is funny that like when you meet
someone in adulthood sometimes you just
kind of assumed that's how they've
always been so like in my head I've
always been tall yeah even in ninth
grade which it doesn't make sense like
everyone goes through puberty why would
everyone be what was everyone always
tall and this
and yeah and yeah like the level of
popularity like in my head your teenage
you is like adult you wear your charming
you're cool you're good-looking dude you
have friends you're great hockey or all
these different things and like you were
probably one of the [ __ ] guys yet
well look I was annoying as [ __ ] when I
was younger I know that I was annoying I
was insecure I um I didn't I was and and
the the thing I think about too when I
in high school when I graduated I was
friends with everybody
yeah but when people graduated you take
pictures with your clicks right huh so
everybody got together with the cliques
and I didn't have a clique to take a
picture with because I was always Friday
I'll hang out with them sadder I'll hang
out with them Tuesday I'll eat lunch
with them okay Friday like you know I
was always like just kind of like going
through and bouncing through and I'd
hang out with these guys for a week and
then so I never had a clique which I'd
never dawn on me until I graduated I was
like oh [ __ ] I don't have a clique I've
just always been by myself which I never
realized but not like a loner because
you were pot like you were friend not a
loner yeah I was I was popular I was I
was I was fun to hang out with back and
I was always cracking jokes
so what clique did you end up taking the
photo with he had to assume but folks I
took pictures with my folks and then
afterwards I remember even everybody got
together with their friends and parents
and went to like Pizza Hut or something
yeah I went out with my parents you know
I hung out with my folks and that was
kind of it and so I think like in
college and then definitely in stand-up
like knowing knowing that you're
comfortable in this especially
professional solitude yeah like I'm fine
being alone yeah I enjoy being alone and
I don't need to be with the same group
of people all the time I think in some
ways maybe it's hurt my career because I
was never friends with like if you
literally turn on any trailer for a
movie that is starring comedian or has
comedians in it or any of these TV shows
it's very cliquey it's the same group of
people all the time and I just was
always like you know yeah I'm friends
with them but I'm not like gonna hang
out with them Friday Saturday night and
stuff like I'm like usually please yeah
yeah and I've just always been that way
with even stand up I just been like
friends with everybody but there's very
few people I actually what are you
wearing tonight came from you didn't
like kind of like buy into like this is
the group I'm gonna Bleich was there
just like something in you that never
wanted to like always be associated with
one group of people like it was it like
I want to just be I want to spread it
around and be popular and know that I
can you know be friends with everyone
and go home and I just like be myself I
like freaking things out on my own I
like to I like to take walks by myself
when I first moved to LA I just dream
going up and down Venice I sit outside
watch the stars of the moon I just sit
for an hour think of all the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do [ __ ] do this I'm gonna do
that it's gonna be [ __ ] great I would
just dream and you couldn't do that if
you're drinking with your with your
bodies and stuff only me I was trying to
get laid I was trying to meet girls who
do stuff after shows but I was always
always just dreaming and even now you
know my wife will go to bed kids go to
bed don't let my headset oh that's yeah
I'll try to a lot of people did not buy
their you know what a wife kid lesbian
to care okay I'll just walk around and
you just think and I really like doing
that I like I've always had that too
like I I mean I was the opposite of you
I didn't like get to the end of high
school and have a lot I still ended up
only having two or three friends I was
very withdrawn
yeah it was not popular it just didn't
work out for me and then but being alone
I was I grew to be very comfortable with
that
yeah I could always a count on that and
I could at you know think and and and
and I had known already I wanted to do
stand-up like during high school but
like yeah it became like a good career
choice for the solitude part you know
yeah I think I think like you know even
doing stand-up you and I have worked
together quite a bit and we're two
people that literally when the show's
done we could go to a diner we go to bar
we go back to the hotel and just kind of
crash and see a movie or whatever
and I think there are a lot of people
that can't cope with that loneliness
yeah and I'm not saying all comics when
stereotyped but I think a lot of
majority of comics do hit the sauce or
smoke pot because they can't cope with
being alone or they can't cope with you
know the isolation of the profession
yeah it is funny like I for me like I
have so much to die and find so much to
do I'll fill my schedule with like all
this stuff that like it just interests
me like you know if we go to whatever
city I'll be like oh cool I can't wait
to like check out this go here there's
not enough time in a day sometimes for
me where we'll meet up for lunch or like
dinner before the show yeah it's like
what you do and I'm like why did this
visit it there what did I wish I had
time for this maybe tomorrow yeah I
would you to be like I was writing I did
this I was on the phone said like 'hey--
we fill our days with [ __ ] yeah I was
just lonely all day well those are the
comics I think they go I just wake up
before it's crazy yeah yeah what are you
running from yeah yeah yeah I like to
just figure but yeah I mean certain
people end up learning how to like use
that like you know solitary time and
like yeah not resent it or or you know
feel like depressed within it yeah which
I guess is a it's pretty useful because
there's going to be times in life where
you're alone you know completely yeah
yeah and I think it's I look I I think
that there are you know you there dog or
cat yeah I'm definitely a cat I like to
be by myself I like to figure things out
on my own I don't mind going to the
movie by myself I don't mind going to
restaurant by myself I'm totally
comfortable sitting in a restaurant
without even my phone and eating there
and just daydreaming setting and eating
food some people say I can't do that now
crazy layup I couldn't imagine I'm like
why not are you worried while people are
watching and go
that guy's alone or she's not with any
friends it's like who cares yeah I
prefer eating I really do prefer eating
alone a lot of the time like in
especially if I'm I know I'm going to be
doing stuff later on
well I'm just like I want this hour to
myself and then I'm gonna go hang out
with [ __ ] nine people for the next
four hours a show yeah give me a minute
you know it's even like what Stan up to
I think sometimes you know like when I
go home or I go to like justice family's
place or sometimes I'll hang out with a
group of friends I'm so quiet I don't
say anything yeah and it's just like
like why are you so quiet it's just like
I just spent four days just being the
center of attention
yeah and talking to 350 people for hours
hours straight
last thing I want to do is talk and
after the show yet missed 30 40 minutes
sometimes where you're like taking
pictures saying hi having conversations
it's like it ends up being like three or
four hours at night sometimes yeah the
last person I want to hear talk is
myself yeah I don't want to I want to
have run out of [ __ ] to say for now yeah
let me be quiet by myself and I think of
you thoughts and ideas I want to explore
yeah I just want to put my headphones in
and listen to no Gallagher yeah our
weekend for an hour straight not think
it has anything that's it yeah are you
close with your parents now much closer
than I look when I was younger I was
always close with my folks but I think
like because they stayed together
they're still together still together
now that's cool and when you're I think
when you're in high school you take your
parents for granted you know going
through so much hormonal E that you're
just I was on edge all the time I was I
had a short fuse I didn't want anything
to do with my parents [ __ ] away from me
hanging off my friends and bombers [ __ ]
out the you know angry and just confused
and and then you know you get a college
and you're independent you appreciate
them a little bit more and throughout
the duration of my career they've been
nothing but supportive my first two
months of stand-up three months maybe
four months of stand-up open mics New
York City they were my two paying
customers so I could do five minutes of
stand-up that's everyone hard on weekend
and I'm telling ya they sat through some
shitty shows
oh yeah that's your my horseshit yeah
two hours three hours at sit there and
just sit there and or
coke or order sprite and watch horseshit
and you know when you get a show on the
air and then your mom is being portrayed
on that it's just like that's when it's
worth it when your parents saw me on The
Tonight Show for the first time they're
like so [ __ ] proud and so that
galvanized you but I think ultimately
what really makes adulthood come full
circle is when you have another child
because everything it's almost like
you're seeing life on the other side of
the mirror yeah you can look at yourself
every day but now you're kind of on the
other side and you're seeing the real
you you're not looking at a reflection
of you you're seeing you and I had a
different appreciation for my parents
everything just the first time you hold
a kid you're like as much it's almost
like you don't know what love truly is
until you hold a child in your arms
because you have a different type of
love for a child but you also experience
the love that your parents gave you
under steer ially understand yeah yeah
you never truly can love your parents I
think until you have a kid that's just
my own personal pity because once that
happened everything just clicked for me
and I understood everything they ever
did well it was almost like somebody
plugged that matrix plug in the back
your head you like I didn't you're
online now and I'm just apologized for
everything you ever did you say I love
you for everything you'd ever did and
for me at least for my upbringing I know
everybody has different upbringing some
people are bad childhood some of my
childhood my parents war is great always
supportive they you know is never trophy
generation is never like you know you
got to earn everything you be sweet to
everybody you treat people with respect
Golden Rule you're not special you know
you're special to me but you're not
special anybody else you got to earn
special attention you know so really
old-school but until I had kids like now
I give my dad a hug and we just embrace
for two or three more seconds more and
that's the difference you know and my
mom I talked to a little bit more on the
phone and I hug them just a second
um it you know I get it now I totally
got it no that's just my own perception
I know people have different experiences
and it'll relay into what they convey
but for me I think you can love a wife
and not me but people's wives come and
go I just think that that child that you
have it just what I see like an NBA
player has like eight kids it's like
[ __ ] can you do that how [ __ ] can you
have a kid and just like not even be in
that kid's life but just think I'm gonna
write a check again is like III don't
know having kids is the greatest
experience of my life by far it's just
the best are you gonna have to now yeah
why are you gonna have like another one
yeah yeah it's the single greatest thing
ever no more kids no more kids yeah it
is
reward I mean - sounds like plenty I
mean I have a younger brother and we
were I mean plenty for my parents it was
yeah so much to do especially with me in
California it's like I can't afford
another kid oh yeah yeah this place you
can text applause ooh the pelvis schools
suck you know paying property taxes mi
ski it's just like it's six grand for
for preschool when I went to Kent State
it was eight grand for the year oh my
god and these kids take a nap and
crayons and it's six grand what the [ __ ]
are they what kind of crayon Christ it's
like my next TV credit should be the
price is right so I can get some money
yeah to like live it's fun yeah yeah um
you know holy [ __ ] so I've heard you
talk a lot about like the values you
want to like instill in your kids from
like your parents and yeah you know what
they gave you that sort of thing I mean
they grew up in like a different time
obviously and yeah and a lot of the a
lot of the things that you you know talk
about it like from from that era are
there things that like that you kind of
learned or saw growing up like from
either your family or the other families
in the neighborhood of community that
you're like I don't want to carry that
over
into yeah I love this modern day and
here are things that I disagree because
you have like your your outlook on a lot
of things is like is very like
independent and is there to like build a
solid person you know like that yeah you
know pick yourself up by the bootstraps
you you earn success that there's no
trophies you like I love all that stuff
like I think that that makes you like a
tough individual and I heard you the one
you did my new material so you started
working on a bit about yeah I'm
obviously won't do is say I say like
about what makes you kind of like a
solid individual and that's another
thing where I'm like yes that you know
and those are things you don't hear that
much of this people I mean you do you do
but you also are now hear people say
more like well um we should be we should
complain more about things and you know
kind of just get things without trying
in a certain way yeah and part of me
falls somewhere in the middle because
you go
sometimes the deck is stacked against
you sometimes are unfair yeah and it's
not always as easy as like I got to like
just you know try and get things done
right you know so I think like you get
to a point where you go like I need a
little from column in like a little from
column B so like what for you personally
are you gonna like say I won't do this
the way the previous generations did for
like my for my kids in my family I think
there's a whole generation of kids and
again I'm not I don't want to you know
stereotype Millennials or whatever but I
I think for every kid that grew up you
know being part of a trochee generation
there's not a kid that came from the
school of hard knocks so I'm not going
to generalize and say it all but right I
think for me personally when it comes to
my kids growing up it's like and
especially you and I both know coming up
in stand-up comedy this is one of the
most difficult profession it's so
unforgiving there's very few professions
that are so unregulated it literally is
the Wild West there is no Sheriff there
is no pres
there is no corporate entity that is
going to say you know it's Yousef Stern
right it's burns turn nobody and now
what I'm gonna do that is you and so I
don't tell my kids this world doesn't
owe you [ __ ] nobody owes you [ __ ] I
don't owe you [ __ ]
you don't owe you [ __ ] the only person
that is going to attain anything for you
is you rest determined upon how much
you're willing to work and earn it but
ultimately you know you want to be happy
whatever you you choose to do because
you know we're two people who followed
our bliss and I know for a fact on my
worst day as a stand-up comic it's
better than my best day in a cubicle
yeah in a convert you know weird
universe where Steve Byrne is in Ohio
you know talking excited to go golfing
with his boss and go home together
promotes just like I could care let that
let that life is absolutely my nightmare
yeah but in terms of like kids these
days and I think the outlook right now
like right now it's socially acceptable
to look if you're going to think it's
it's stereotypical to think every time a
cop pulls over a black person that black
person deserves to be pulled over it's
like well that's [ __ ] horrible well I
mean yeah that's a stereotype you
shouldn't think that all black people
criminal they're obviously not right and
I think that all these great
documentaries that are coming out show
that and everything every time there's
something on the news it's like you know
when is this set of our population going
to catch a break and just just get the
respect that every human being should be
given without being generalized so if
you go under it under the guise of that
then I think you should also go under
the guise of not generalizing
stereotyping white people because right
now it is in a fashion to say that there
is white privilege well to anybody who
truly believes that there is white
privilege in terms of well you're white
you can drive down the street not get
pulled over by a cop okay well that's
that's the argument you hear but I'll
tell you there's somebody who grew up in
the Rust Belt Drive to West Virginia you
know watch cops cops is
it's not all black it is a lot of white
you can say white trash you can vilify
white people on CNN they you know they
prefer a you know they generalize some
Trump voters as white trash it's like
why is it that you can say that I think
it's really really disrespectful in
terms of this because they're in power
you can like you can [ __ ] on the people
if like I guess kicking someone while
they're down it's like I mean come to
already had it bad enough like yeah but
if if the ultimate goal is to garner
respect from everybody and have
everybody on an equal playing field
saying you know what I respect you as my
equal you respect me as you if you want
respect then you gotta give respect and
you tired identify to the degree that I
think our country is doing right now in
terms of the political spectrum right um
and I think racially white people for
the last eight years have been this
unsolicited punching bag where you go on
Huffington Post like look at all these
white people together something bad is
going to happen it's like that's such a
shitty clickbait kind of thing and again
it goes against what that person that
wrote that article ultimately wants is
for that an equal playing field and true
respect amongst everybody and that's
always been my perspective and I think I
want to I absolutely want to pass it
down to my kids dead respect everybody
across the board yeah and nobody look
the 1% in this country those are the
people that that should get [ __ ] on
because those kids are growing up the
Hilton's the Kardashians these kids that
just walk into a blissful life that just
have money yeah you know that's that's
who I understand getting difficult it'll
guff delay you gotta earn your keep yeah
so what about something like I guess a
good example for like the things that
were that people accepted in the past
and I guess don't now do a degree
something like bullying yeah like that
something is that something you could
argue like you know makes a man or an
adult or whatever and like yeah there's
a healthy amount
that that probably will prepare you for
a life of you know of potential
hardships like dude yeah what why they
only aim because I'm in somewhere in the
middle on that I was bullied and
everybody's bully it scarred me in some
ways for sure but then in other ways I'm
like man this can't be as bad as when I
was just like an unsure insecure like
you know kid who didn't know you know
anything about about the world
I think bullying is a tough subject
because it is such a great look you and
I grew up we got [ __ ] on we got made fun
of you feel like an [ __ ]
yeah cry about it you know what are you
gonna do yeah you go on with your life
right I cannot imagine growing up with
with the magnitude of having an
embarrassing situation played out on the
Internet you know globally or not not
just your township not because a high
school is confined within the bricks of
that high school right and if you're
embarrassed in school okay [ __ ] but if
you move to New York City now I give a
[ __ ] about you are scarred and branded
for life by an incident that could be on
the internet that could go viral yeah or
even a thousand people see it it's
embarrassing so I get that aspect and
did these kids they like kill themselves
or commit suicide with the bullying I
think the schools need to do a better
job right policing it especially online
bullying because that's I think 95% of
the [ __ ] that goes down with these kids
it comes from being embarrassed because
these kids put such a commodity and the
likes and retweet and they're social any
day never ends at least like when we
were in school you could be bullied and
yeah 3:05 p.m. you're like okay it's
over till 8:00 exactly tomorrow morning
yeah go home and get my lunch money and
okay yeah yeah tomorrow go to the arcade
hang out at home watch TV like kind of
decompress and get away from it but the
bullying never ends now there's a little
on your phone on your phone on your
computer there's you're hearing about it
24 hours a day it's got to be like it's
got to be crazy unless like they're I
mean used to a two-degree that we never
wore if you grow up kind of like you
know yeah always online
but bullying is a part of life I mean it
is yeah as much as you don't want to
acknowledge it look kids are [ __ ]
mean yeah they're always gonna be mean
and I part of life yeah
are you gonna tell me that you went to
the bank to get a loan you didn't get
bullied or you can tell me that if you
owe the IRS money that they're not gonna
[ __ ] bully you and call you and shut
down your bank accounts right and ruin
you know any transaction you want to
there if you owe the government money
you're gonna get bullied every facet of
the way yeah you're good at your jobs
yeah you get bullied as a stand-up I
mean yeah you get bullied by the
audience you get [ __ ] on [ __ ] you you're
not [ __ ] funny
yeah [ __ ] maybe I'm not I don't know and
then you take that to heart of course it
hurts
bullied everywhere so you got to get
used you can't outlaw bullying but I
think especially these days when it
comes to kids and it comes to social
media the schools need to do a better
job and communities and the townships
need to do a better job at cracking down
on that and I'm not I don't believe ever
in zero tolerance but there needs to be
like a 95% yeah you know intolerance of
that stuff and find a way to correct it
because it's so new that they haven't
found it yet but yeah they do hopefully
they find it before my [ __ ] kids goes
I was gonna say like it being a parent
now must be just so like there's so much
uncharted territory yeah technology's
changing every five [ __ ] days where
you're like okay well now how do i what
do i do look there's things that you
have yet to understand because they're
just happening and then you know like
pass that on to like the kids and you
know who knows what is going on in
school in terms of like what access they
have to devices and and all this sort of
stuff it must be like I mean the anxiety
and the sort of like constant attention
to to making sure like you have a handle
on every new thing yeah the thing that
sucks I think in with foresight is that
you and I grew up without the internet
yeah okay in our formative years so
there's no there's no time capsule from
back then that you could look up yeah I
mean people went for example people went
back to Tom Hardy's MySpace and found
some pictures we're going embarrassing
and they put it up and
hosted and it's kind of funny was that I
got a link that recently yeah how cool I
get that funny stuff like that's
underwear and shared needs being goofy
yes but these kids now from the age of
you know whenever you get a cell phone
eight nine ten whatever they have these
little social media platforms for kids
right and these kids are putting things
out there that decades from now could
come back and haunt them and that to me
is scary
yeah that to me is like why are you
going to judge a kid for what he did
with his 10 or 13 yeah 18 or 22 you know
they should have the the ability because
it happens when every come anytime a
stand-up comic gets something great you
get booked on SNL you get it you're on
TV show some [ __ ] reporter from Gawker
a vulture or AV Club [ __ ] ain't going
to go through your Twitter timeline look
at what this racist tweet he wrote yeah
yeah you know when he had the Twitter
account for two months he said something
immature yeah what he can do
yeah he should be he should be able to
do that yeah Wow
are you gonna teach your kids Korean
they're a quarter so probably it's just
like a handful of words yeah my mom
actually teaches my daughter my daughter
actually picked it up she she still
knows Korean words to this day who uses
every now and then and she speaks
gibberish and tries to pretend she
doesn't like her in my son but uh but it
should be something they're in touch
with because it is it is the quality
that will that will make them different
and you know it is part of their history
and I think it should be something that
they should be proud of as much as that
they are Irish as well yeah oh yeah I
guess like I mean how in touch with you
with your Irish I think a lot more
because of the Jameson but uh but I've
been to Dublin two or three times and
Koreans and Irish have a very similar
history and I think it really does brood
through in my personality that these are
two land masses that have been fought
over for centuries
just ward over and so there is this
chip-on-the-shoulder right Koreans are
known to be the Irish of the Asians
because they're so outgoing they like to
party they're not as they're not as
isolated and like you know you go to
another country like Japan could you
they there's almost like this recluse
kind of quality that the Asians have
even in this country rape an firm yeah
Asians you know and I think this goes to
a bigger picture of the fact that why
Asians aren't more prominent in pop
culture's because Asians in general have
come to this country in mass and done
everything they can to assimilate yeah
and through assimilation they've lost a
sense of identity true and so because of
that there aren't these pop culture mile
posts that have you know littered our
nation's pop culture history yeah which
is kind of sad so hopefully the method
that's been starting it's starting to
change starting to a lot of like ethnic
groups you know you'll see more
representation of like diversity casting
it's like okay so so Yang's in Silicon
Valley or well you know so you know
there's there's just like these little
shows or like well the yeah I agree
that's like kind of like oh oh you guys
are complaining well here's a guy in a
show now yeah you find that to be kind
of like offensive a little bit when you
know every commercials the black cherry
i but i think i mean that now there
you'll see more like examples kind of
like a margaret show or like a and Aziz
Ansari where these guys are coming into
their own and they're like yeah you're
not just casting me as the Asian friend
or the Indian like I'm my own thing and
I'm beyond being like a Korean or an
Indian this and like I think there's
more of those people starting to surface
because there is an audience for it and
it does it it doesn't have to be like
based on an ethnicity and entertainment
and you know stuff is just becoming more
of a global thing so like you know the
Indian comedian or the Asian
you know actor is not just playing to
the lower 48 yeah yeah the world Aziz
and you know barring Cosby his current
situation right now but Cosby Show is
great because yeah it was a family that
happened we were like yeah Aziz is a
great talent that happens to be in it
yeah and I think that's it doesn't
matter well it just is the story great
is what they're communicating
interesting and I think that's why Jesus
showed as well I think that's why The
Cosby Show did well yeah and so on and
so forth I think that's why Margaret is
truly a pioneer for asian-americans and
I think just female comics in general
and and in the in a pantheon of great
comics I think she's definitely there as
well because your stand-up stands on its
own and again she just happens to be
Asian
she had an email and she happens to be
tatted and all the other different
qualities you can bring up about her but
yeah that becomes kind of like one of
the more important things I think Leo
mentioning and talking about it but not
like having an actor or something that's
like hinged on that I think ends up
being yeah yeah like even I've never
known you to be like the guy who talks
about being half this half that like
you've had jokes about it yeah you know
but you're more like I think it goes way
further to just show people like I'm a
person and here's my life in my
background and here's like the rainbow
of things that make up Steve Byrne or
Nick or whatever that more than anything
does a better job of just showing that
you're like me I'm like you were like
completely yes or whatever I think I've
been inconsistent throughout the
duration of my career in terms of being
inclusive of everybody not exclusive to
a sect of the population yeah and it
always has been under the banner of
being proud of this country and American
and my second hour was American flag and
my third my fourth hour
it was truly just a flagon up my name
and this nice house and go Russian flood
we
like yeah exactly ever you are at it
right now more like whoa what happened
but uh but yeah I I appreciate that
thank you uh noting that but yeah I
think it's I I also never wanted to
betray one side of my family right and
my mom's like Lee Allen talked about
your dad yeah like cuz that all sin you
are Carlos Mencia it's just like but
you're Ned and you're half German
where's the Oktoberfest jokes and you
know exactly does that happen just you
know then you're doing it just to do it
but look I get why Carlos does that it's
probably because all his life he's been
told by people in a really shitty
demeaning way he's Hispanic he's
different
you're [ __ ] you don't count yeah and
so when you take that on it's like oh
I'm gonna [ __ ] flip the narrative rye
am going to be Hispanic Bonnie [ __ ]
funny and we rich and famous and he did
it and he flipped it but I think when
you poke at it and truly go to that
person's identity you know well you're
half German - yeah it I mean it is a
difficult like it's a difficult like
Road I mean you did a really good job
like doing you know representing like
both sides of you know who you are and
like where you grew up like you're a
part of your identity is informed by you
know growing up in Pittsburgh if you
grew up yeah Seattle things probably
would have been different or tacky on us
or you know so you you you do a good job
of like confidently like you know
representing like here is all the things
that make up you know Steve Byrne is
like a person and a comedian and stuff
but I think that there is that route to
where you you know you're told like even
if you are half German or half whatever
if you look like you're more this people
go now we don't accept that we're going
to tell you that and it just it's a mind
[ __ ] you ultimately you don't know where
you land it's up to you it's updated
ahead it's up to Carlos it's up to
whoever it is yeah but you don't know
that whatever what a big major you know
I didn't know that like I I like as I've
gotten older to like I did a pretty good
job like assimilating and looking like I
just I'm one of the [ __ ] guys a very
like light-skinned for an Arab yeah so
some people will be like well I've
always thought of you as white and then
I've always been like I bet I guess what
I wanted but I there is I'm an I'm of
Lebanese I'm a Middle Eastern you go to
my house is Arabic screen smoking it's
not like garlic all over the place
that's my whole life yeah it's like you
know what it was like growing up so like
when I was younger I didn't know how to
manage it you know and as an adult you
find like it's not about what you or all
these other people think I'm going to
take some soul exactly of my identity
and what how much of it I am gonna like
put out there or or own or you know or
whatever but I mean it's part of the
reason I'm doing this but you know yeah
well I think it's a great yeah podcast I
think it's a great vessel because at the
end of the day everybody at some point
in their life felt like they didn't fit
in exactly felt like an outcast yeah and
this is I think a really great podcast
for kids in high school or college to
listen to because that's when you're
really figuring it out you know I
remember when I first moved to New York
City Marc Maron said it takes ten years
to become an overnight success in comedy
and he he was not your 18 week and he
was like it's going to take you ten
years to develop your voice it's going
to take you 10 years to figure out who
you are and I'm like [ __ ] that yeah I
figured out this guy and I realized well
it took me I think 15 years to figure
out my voice because yeah it just took
me a little bit longer and I think and
that was after you were already really
good doing stuff yeah you were
destroying everywhere you were working a
time you were like yeah yeah yeah yeah I
was I was destroying the like a modest
but you are already like a incredibly
skilled comedian you're headlining your
European but I don't write for yourself
that other than what you're passionate
about and I think that when you're
growing up once once you could put a
curly one on the soap okay that's when
it starts and you're figuring things out
yeah and once that happens you're like
who the [ __ ] am I and I think this is a
great introduction to that
that hot guys that's why I hey I said
yeah of course cuz because of you but
when you told me about the foundation of
this I'm like I think this did would be
great for young kids and it's to hear
this because it is so formative in terms
of your identity and where you choose to
align yourself and I it took me just a
while but I was like for me was like
Bern identity is what I said I'm
American I'm tired of like being Korean
and Irish I'm American because America
truly is a melting pot and is everybody
from all over the world just accepting
one another respecting one another
ultimately is what it should be
yeah instead of breaking off a little
part of that yes I'm gonna hang out with
Bobby Lee and Ken Jeong the rest of my
life it's okay only thing though yeah
yeah it would be crazy it'd be crazy to
do that and I wouldn't because I'm a cat
right yeah yeah yeah and that's
something you only were able to figure
out being you know being an outcast and
being this being that where you go like
wall I'm there's so many options you
could be a little bit of you know
everything and then in the end still be
like ya know an American guy named Steve
yeah and like with you whenever I I ran
into you at the at the comic store early
on I was just so as Nick I never would
have assumed anything else and yeah
Simone's not some yep Italian yeah
exactly yeah he's just like that's
Simone I I just I I don't know maybe was
growing up in Jersey and growing up
around kids from all different
backgrounds but predominately must of
them were Jewish and yeah I just I don't
I just never think that maybe if I grew
up in Iowa then it's just what wipe you
all the time and a black kid moved there
in junior High's God think differently
but I just never have had that in me
yeah unless I'm on stage and then you
can trash somebody's ethnicity oh you
know 100 things that you can't just go
that's right down the line here at the
eight stereotypes and I'm gonna go in on
I thought that I just remove oh yeah
enjoy your night yes I like what the
[ __ ] you know that guy but yeah I think
that's a part of what makes like this
whole experience like so fun is it you
know you're open-minded enough about it
like you'll just meet a lot of cool
people with a lot of different
backgrounds and you just kind of like
you know take what's in front of you
it's like yeah cool
who you are great let's now be friends
and move on and yeah and and I think
it'll just be it's going to keep moving
in that direction you know yeah every
time you turn on your TV or you watch a
movie there's someone else being
portrayed in a way that goes against a
stereotype we've always kind of grown
grown up seeing you know whether it is
white or black or whatever the race is
from white on you know down it I mean
ethnicities that you didn't even know
really existed or you know places where
you're like what what's a Lao Asian
person you know right people that are
just I've never even heard of that you
know soon enough those people will just
be portrayed as you know a guy or a girl
playing this role or being a comedian
talking about area children or [ __ ]
traffic or whatever the thing is yeah
and then that'll just be a thing that's
kind of looked back on it I remember
when we used to treat you know yes and
gays and Latinas and whatever like this
and that and honor that's why I just saw
that uh that Wonder Woman movie oh yeah
I'm gonna and there was this guy he was
you know like Middle Eastern his name is
Sammy and he was giving his backstory to
Wonder Woman he's like she's like why
are you so good at this and he was like
the smooth operator and I could get
anything and you know he could speak all
these languages and stuff and he's like
he's like well I've always want to be an
actor but I look like this so I had to
do what I had to do and he just like
it's such a great line but it's so like
I know the movie takes place during
World War one but it was written now
it's like another one of those things
we're just like you just keep piling
enough straws right on the camel's back
that is the country in terms of again
accepting one another and understanding
we're all just trying to get through
life together right and eventually you
put enough of those straws it'll break
and guys like Sammy
there were portrayed World War one I
mean imagine being you know an Iranian
actor or imagine you're you know Afghani
and you want to come here and you look
like Danny DeVito but your passionate
stage and acting it's like who the
[ __ ] gonna what Lola for that guy
right now you know yeah and it's just
like the guy was
you know I was born like this and you
just you know you hope to god that at
some point we have that spectrum of
people from all over you know being
represented but I think it's also you
can't be dependent upon Hollywood to
write that for her yeah it's got it's
got to come from within it's got to be
Asians if you're not well represented in
the NBA well you know what get better at
basketball yeah if you want to see more
Persians playing in the NFL well then
[ __ ] get your kids playing it's not
up to the NFL to make this happen
it's not up to Hollywood I feel it's not
up to Hollywood to put more people it
just shoehorn them in a row so it's like
why do we need a black James Bond I
don't want to see a black James Bond I
want to see James Bond the way it's
spent the last however many decades
unless it's Edra Selva he would make a
great James Bond he'd be great there why
not create a vehicle for him because
Madhavan can be the Bourne Identity Tom
Cruise can do Mission Impossible
you could brand those James Bond films
just as easily so why can't you make a
black version of that why does it have
to be it to me it's just lazy it's like
let's make spider-man black it's like
why why can't you just make a great
black superhero
why can't you be creative enough within
your own community to do something like
that cause it was it would go it would
show that it doesn't matter because a
lot of people grow up grew up thinking
like certain things or white and certain
things are black and certain things of
this you can make spider-man black would
show that it certain things don't have
to be white they can be anything well
yeah look if you're going to reboot it
and make him Puerto Rican Porto Rican
like the comics or you know this young
girl she's like Hispanic and she's going
to be the new Iron Man it's like okay
you could reboot it and do it that way
yeah that's that's fun and I get it and
you're going under the marketing
principle that people buy that because
it's an Iron Man comic book right but I
just think don't be lazy work a little
[ __ ] harder and create something even
better because this is Hollywood full of
creative people yeah and you like it
create a new superhero that is just a
guy or a girl
that is you know has Ironman like things
like qualities or whatever the hell
that's it or even whatever just a new
thing that just happens to be a human
that has superpowers that is out there
saving the world from bad guys yeah and
then cast them as a Lao Asian guy that's
even how you say it lo Asian languages
but yeah and I think that you know you
you do we are seeing more of that now
because there's so many Adventist Amazon
Netflix Showtime HBO like all these
different networks that are just like
waiting for amazing content and people
like here's a show about you know 17th
century France and blah blah blahs have
me like don't it never aired on NBC yeah
it's so specific but Lango unchained
right that that could have been that
could have spawned 100 sequels right
he's now a bounty hunter right he's out
there so because it's Tarantino it's
going to be one off but why can't
Hollywood create this you know the
addictive kind of like superhero bounty
hunter that learned this skill set and
now he's off on his own that have been
[ __ ] awesome yeah and if it was
another somebody at the helm maybe it
could happen so I'm just saying
Joffrey novels are good about that
though just know ya know just like write
characters and then at you know it
doesn't matter what race or ethnicity it
is because there's no like they're not
marketing it towards you know middle
America or wherever they're just like
here's the story and this characters
black and that characters this and then
go back to the history comics what was
it it was a bunch of skinny Jews trying
to make money post depression right and
they're going to sit there and daydream
and get creative wouldn't be cool if I
could fly and I wasn't this skinny wiry
guy if I was handsome and and so what's
he can do he's going to draw a better
version of himself right and become
Superman I'm going to draw a better
version which I'm spider-man if it was
in high school with this and so there's
a black kid out there right now it's
wondering why is there black superhero
right a better version of you and
daydream and get creative yeah and lo
and behold maybe ten years from now
we'll have a black superhero that is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] because yeah it's taken
this long to get Wonder Woman the
friendly Nell superhero that people are
like
like this is [ __ ] amazing right of
course it is it should be no different
it's a great story that's that's the
bottom line so exactly if you are a
minority or you feel an outcast in
Hollywood you could sit there and knock
on every door and wait for somebody to
hire you or again going back to like
pull your right foot your boots up yeah
why not you're right you're wrong
vehicle and instead of waiting for
somebody hire you start your own
business yeah and start it out and is
this your way of telling me that you're
writing a Korean American superhero the
well character that everybody the Hulk
do you know that they did that with the
Hulk running again they're doing another
they rebooted the Hulk but he's actually
half asian what so they did that yeah
and of course they're she's gonna be a
greenish yellow yes now how dare you
make a joke yeah wow that's cool yes he
could be [ __ ] anything he ends up
becoming a giant green monster serum
looking cares on his background the
serum could have been given to anybody's
that having I grew that Superman there's
a meth owes it is you know it's very
specific to him you know Batman is very
specific him and it's it's been decades
and it's such an iconic thing that's
like we don't need to make a black
Batman in my opinion again it would be
lazy it's just like why not get creative
yeah and create something eventually you
do even better a canoe even aside from
like recasting as with a different like
race it's like yeah I just am tired of
seeing reboots of the same [ __ ]
stories it's like how many times are we
gonna redo Batman I don't care who's
playing them yeah already like come up
with a new guy yeah like just start over
yeah with a new thing yeah are we done
with progress and in terms of creativity
like it's only Batman's and Superman's
and spider-man's from here on out yeah
well sometimes they can't even get those
rights so until they get it live and
learn did it they got it right with
literals yeah to me it was like after
those movies I was like sweet we're done
with Batman alright yeah move on and
then they go oh yeah we're recasting
Batman again I'm like what when will it
end
yeah are we going to have 45 different
right sam raimi had two great ones yeah
[ __ ] up with a third one it's over he
didn't [ __ ] up the third one book but
someone audio way up a third he was
trying to go spent and then they
rebooted again it's we're okay another
reboot it again
it's unreal to me yeah it's like just
start that you every single year there's
like a you know a world full of kids
that are waiting to crack open a new you
know comic book or watch anything that
could be the generation that goes that's
our new superhero I can't wait to watch
more of that you know cartoon or movie
or whatever it is and then 20 years down
the line that becomes the next whatever
Superman Batman yeah exactly whatever
you want to make it but they seem to not
be ready to do that like that it's just
like they assume people are like yeah
they're not smart enough to learn about
a new superhero we just have to keep
showing them the same one it's like you
know we get our hero story introduce a
new one and let it learn about that guy
well even look at what Star Wars is done
I mean Star Wars did you know in terms
of like race you go that way but like
gender I mean they took the last two
Star Wars films that have come out and
their female lead your protagonist is
female so it's like it's much praised
we're going to give Wonder Woman it's
like Star Wars did this two years ago
already yeah it did it a year ago
yeah and they knew that the guys were
going to come regardless because it
stores phone and I think marketing wise
they're like let's get everywhere let's
get some girls in here and as a guy
you're watching you know these six other
films that were male lead and then you
watching this one just like it doesn't
matter who as long as the story is great
and you know yeah this matter who's yeah
I never even really like paid that much
attention to like I never gave a [ __ ]
until afterwards someone's like it was a
girl Lita it's like oh yeah it was
because it's kind of cool yeah for me
I'll add I guess please make a good Star
Wars story I was really turned like you
know I'm sure maybe some people go and
going like oh yeah can't wait for this
star isn't oh there's a chick in here
like yeah sure some people do that but
it did boil down to like get a story
which I was like yeah that was the Star
Wars movies cool and then I'm like you
know moved on my life had they done that
for films ago put a woman in yeah that
would have gone a lot further because
people were still like Star
yeah yeah that would have gone way
further the prequels yeah yeah yeah you
know yeah hopefully there's like a new
there's a new superhero thing that in
ten years we can look back on they go
finally they put they put the reviving
Batman thing bed and now we got this new
guy or girl or transgendered whatever
like who's the [ __ ] what it is well I
don't give a [ __ ] what as long as it's a
fun story
yeah exact score a story you can lead
character you can root for that's all
hey what it matters I think you're super
here name what was the thing that you
called yourself on the bus what did I
come to the to the bully remember Oh
crusher bone Smith crusher bone Smith
temporarily yeah that's just after he
ran in [ __ ] ha you want to end it
sure let's do an hour and a half oh god
yeah that was a long one yeah it's about
how long they got our those hours about
he an hour 45 that's great yeah
so returns we keep talking the micro is
it over now this is it okay thanks for
doing it thanks for having me not
appreciate what
[Music]